yo-oh go whoa oh my god what did I whoa
what where's the ball what is Haven I
think we got hit by the ball oh we don't
touch the ball like wow you have to like
hit it oh yeah
Little Caesar color like right now only
green can hit it oh well I guess it was
Green how did you hit it
Oh Oh taste it mmm on the game Felix is
good at no don't worry I'll be losing in
a second it's really hard to get started
Oh No which button is hit again XR the
left one oh that's me okay oh oh whoa oh
my god you guys sauce this how does your
China let him forehead plane you're
trying to boss me I'm trying as much as
I want
oh god damn it dad damn it Ken's gonna
win that just cuz I did that go no one
hits the bowl I love it oh come on oh
okay all right you and me oh I actually
won one what awesome and pretty cool
well that was a [ __ ] there in the
corner
why you there's pretty good dance all
right that was my okay okay okay who's
blue oh I hit me oh my god oh no no
what is happening was awesome but oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up do this again ken-dono
kid kid come on
oh it's eared me can [ __ ] you if you win
- it can do it
oh you hold down it charges about you
and ya stupid power I'm gonna go through
the thing there's powers and it's about
three times a day
first time ever I went to this game I
lost everything last time pointless oh
man
ah yeah Wade you ditched a girl come on
yeah I'm the Gator I got it Gator can
climb walls that's all I know because
I'm walls oh let me try that
oh god I don't like where this is going
Mack god damn it oh my god that's pretty
good Oh No oh you go girl
oh well what is doing down there with
them whoa whoa whoa hey whoa wait there
come the [ __ ] chicken - sit down you're
in your [ __ ] wall lie man oh oh well
there's nothing going on right now I got
nothing
oh god no oh my god it's going so fast
yours
catalyst how is that working
oh my god oh no no which color my I'm
green I keep thinking I'm yellow because
I'm yellow Oh Oh God oh it's again
having the game powers all the way up
you hit like attacked twice and you eat
it oh hello Malayan well so I attack is
the same button attack twice
yeah whatever you're Boris full with the
top oh Jesus what happened oh I see
I butted it can I can I can I hit it I
can't can [ __ ] me dance is funky music
like a longish music [ __ ] oh no it's ah
yeah
what how did that happen I don't know
I'm going back up I'm going back up to
my turn chef [ __ ] is happening oh my god
alright alright here we go
no leg ah guess it's just you and me Mac
you and me agaton me and my [ __ ] it
it's gonna try oh man
I'd yeah oh I looked into you a flavor
for sanada that's nice that laughs after
the who's though jeez no one can mimic
eight how do you change the colors click
on them
oh I can't be that like one now goddamn
it all red hairs yes
you can't even see you what wedding a
little afro gone Mickey Mouse I'll I
Ken's gonna be old
why is it not starting okay cuz gotta
wait I didn't know and nice redhead
thank you I know I like in how spicy
right all right
and Ken are such a gentleman look at his
proper proper man oh I don't know what
color I am Bock what are you guys doing
oh my god I did it Jim oh wow oh geez
[ __ ] oh hey good job pieces I guess man
hammer okay well there are me what jeez
I don't I don't want it I don't want it
[ __ ] I just no no please don't
it's fine ha ha ha ha oh my god Mike
what happened Jesus I don't know I was
really bad then I got really good
apparently for some reason what are you
doing up there just give me a minute I'm
gonna Oh God
Oh My Jesus Oh missile powered Oh
Oh everyone has special power Gator can
grab the ball and eat it instead if I
can even hit it
Oh Oh No
Kevin and snow now it's so fast please
oh my god
Oh God come on you can get it you can
get it come on come on he's gonna get
you unless you get it oh my god what is
happening
what are you doing ah wait then I drop
out of the sky
hello I can't hear you guys
well [ __ ] you - that [ __ ] wins this is
my favourite game haha it's amazing what
the [ __ ] is going on guys
hello I can't hear you can you hear me
Oh Kenny man he's sick cats and family
bring me a treat bum bum bum behaving a
cuter reliable Ben oh god [ __ ] god damn
you saggy tits I'll get you
whoo sagging man sag a man Oh
saggy tits in my bits goddamit right
inside yeah I'm the main why can I hear
you guys escape this is weird everyone
cares I could break my scape hello you
guys in here I can't hear you the [ __ ]
hello Noah are you guys [ __ ] with me
hello Skype this foot oh jesus what a
what's going on yeah what happened you
can't hear me hello what is going on oh
my god
Bruce I'm sorry I loved Dennis episode I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened with
my skype but it was crazy but I won
everything so
pretty proud hell yeah like for me for
once winning all the games and I'll see
you tomorrow as you always stay